i'm going to draw the electrical symbol
for an inductor which is
and this is meant to represent a coil of
wire so it's a coil
of wire
and
in electrical circuits it will be
something like this which is a coil of
wire copper wire
presumably wound on a plastic former and
you can see all the wires in there
in the old days of radio sets which had
capacitors and resistors before module
digital stuff came along you would see
in the back of the radio something like
that with a ferrite rod running through
it and it would be joined to a capacitor
and make a tuned circuit and you know
that this is a coil but these days
people can't take radios to pieces so
they don't actually realize that it's a
simple coil of wire and a simple coil of
wire like that has strange properties
let me take this simple compass needle
and the red is where pointing north now
if i put
a coil of wire
with a current passing through it a
current passing through it causes the
needle to move
it's a source of magnetic field
what happened next was that somebody
called faraday also henry in the united
states of america discovered the laws of
electromagnetism
this is a
method of visualizing the magnetic field
around a bar magnet and this coil of
wire behaves in some ways like a bar
magnet
and in my youth we used to put iron
filings onto a bit of paper and put a
magnet underneath and they would all
line up but if i shake this around a bit
we'll get all the iron filings in
solution
to be
dispersed and you will see that
after a while the iron filings attracted
to both ends of the
bar magnet
can i turn it over and then all fall
over i like playing this is just fun
okay so i've got a north pole here i can
tell it's a north the other side has got
an s written on it we'll have a north
pole
uh coming towards this coil of wire and
this is a coil actually it's more than
you can see here this is just one layer
and they're four layers of this coil so
that makes it a bit bigger i take these
to be my lawful wedding wife i take this
neodymium magnet and put it
near the coil and the magnetic field
goes through this coil it it penetrates
the whole coil and as it does so you see
you get a deflection on here and as i
take it out it goes the other way
so i can make the effect a bit bigger
this is an iron
horseshoe
and it will trap the magnetic field much
better than this only i every time i do
this i forget that this will be sucked
onto the iron so i've got to hurt myself
by putting it down and that actually
increases the magnitude of the effect
and i'm not letting it hit because my
friend george has taught me how to do
this
so the next stage once you've invented
that you know that changing the magnetic
field across a coil
creates an electromagnetic force a
voltage an oscillating voltage and if
you were to take a north and a south
pole and put a coil in there and twist
it around that would have the same
effect and you would then generate
electricity
that's the basis
of power stations
rotating a coil
inside a magnetic field and turning it
into the mains which powers our homes
so this simple invention by faraday
is the basis of most of western
civilization in terms of electrical
supply
there's another thing you can do you can
have another coil this is coil number
one coil number two or normally that's
called the prime this is called the
primary and that's called the secondary
so i'm going to join those together
they're not electrically joined these
are coupled together because i'm going
to create a magnetic field in the iron
bar which will go from there underneath
and through back up there the magnetic
field wants to be trapped inside the
iron
so i'm now going to do the same thing
i'm going to switch on
the current in this coil the current in
this coil produce a magnetic field
the magnetic field travels through this
goes up through that coil and the change
in magnetic field inside this cool
produces a magnetic effect an emf there
so if you watch this
i'll just touch it
and you can see you get a little effect
and there is no direct current passing
through the coil i can make the effect
even bigger if i put
another bit of metal over the top
like that and now we've got a complete
ring of iron going around
which will form a magnetic domain
so now when i touch it and i can get an
electric shock for this so don't try it
at home
this is just a simple battery and now
i'm going to press that on there
and you can see how much bigger the
effect is now
brady look at this as i take it off
this will light up there's a back emf as
i get closer
and i take it off i get a little flash
that's the back emf when you break the
circuit there is a voltage that is
extremely large there in fact
um we estimated yesterday's about 100
volts and that gives you a nasty jolt in
fact the first time i did it and i was
touching everything
it threw me backwards this device is
called a transformer it means that you
can put a voltage in through this
mechanism this battery
a changing voltage in here will then
change into a voltage across there
depending on the number of turns of this
coil and the number of turns of that one
you'll change the voltage from say 240
volts down to 12 or the other way around
you transform the voltage
so you will find this on your digital
dab radio you find it comes out of the
mains at 240 volts you have to put it
through a transformer and it turns it
down to 12 volts and the whole thing
heats up all the time at least i do
you